you
[Music]
it's an honor to to have Peter Norvig
with us today for the Microsoft Research
AI distinguished lecture series I've
known Peter as a colleague and a friend
for many years through our me and Roy
two different organizations over time I
knew Meza and NASA chief scientist and
then as a director of research at Google
it's a pleasure to have him visiting us
today at Microsoft Research peter is
director of research at Google he was
previously head of Google's core search
algorithms group and before that I knew
him for many years as NASA's senior
computer scientist where he was head of
NASA NASA Ames computational Sciences
Division
we had fun this morning in our fireside
chat talking about some of those
experiences which you can cat catch when
that comes out after it's edited Peter
received the NASA exceptional
achievement award in 2001 Peters taught
at the University of Southern California
and at the University of California at
Berkeley from where where he received a
PhD in 1986 and later in 2006 the
Distinguished Alumni Award a few years
back people may recall that a famous New
York Times piece they even added to the
number of students but he code taught an
artificial intelligence class that
signed up 160,000 students and this
actually was one of the the the
conceptual launch points for it became
the this round of massive open online
classes it started right there with a
creative concept from Peter and
colleagues Peters publications include
the books AI a modern approach many of
you have grown up on paradigms of AI
programming case studies in common lisp
verb mobile a translation system for
face-to-face dialogue and intelligent
help systems for unix peter is a fellow
of the triple AI the ACM the California
Academy of Sciences and the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences so Peter
thanks much for accepting our invitation
and coming up to visit us it's been half
having you here thanks Erica it's great
to be here ok so I want to start off by
taking you back in time to 1945 and
Vannevar Bush had this very forward
thinking way of looking at the world he
says that there's going to be new forms
of encyclopedias he didn't use the word
Wikipedia but he was onto something
through this device that he called the
Memex and he had a design for it looks
like this it was a little bit too early
for electronic so this was all optical
so there's microfilm here and there's
projectors up there and then there's a
camera here so you can add your new
notes into this library and this is
basically a researchers tool and this is
how he envisioned the future was gonna
be so we got a lot of things right some
of the things not quite right there was
a famous question on reddit that says if
you could go back to that time there was
two Bush's time and tell somebody what's
the most amazing thing about life today
and the top-rated answer was I have in
my device a pocket that's capable
processing all the information in the
world the Memex basically and I use it
to look at pictures of cats and get in
arguments of strangers
so maybe where we fumbled the future but
it's here and I wanted to just think for
a minute of what this provides you or
any kind of research tool and I think we
can think of it on three levels so one
is you're not quite sure what's going on
and you want help in exploring and
organizing your thoughts and then you're
starting to figure it out and you want
to be able to express your thoughts to
someone else to publish it so that they
can understand what's going on and then
you want to be able to follow the
implications of those thoughts like I
figured out something I have a model of
the world what follows from that model
and the Memex is one way to do that but
we have another amazing tool that Bush
didn't really foresee and oops what
happened my clicker a dialog box popped
up
that's dry again that's better we have
this tool of programming and we have
these core logs so the exploration so
that's things like these Jupiter
notebook so let's just kind of mess
around when we're not quite sure what's
going on and then when we're ready to
publish we can push it to github and all
the world can see it and of course we
can actually run these programs so the
programs have a much better capability
than any other ways we have of
expressing thoughts of saying what are
the implications of this right so I can
write a novel I can write a book and
they're very good at expressing thoughts
but not so good at following through the
implications
whereas programs are great at following
through the implications but they're not
so accessible to everybody in terms of
can you understand what's going on so
let's go through the four words of the
title as what's the history well we've
come a long way here we have a room full
of computers and each one of these is
one bit here we have a room full of
computers and the equivalent size is a
terabyte so we've come a long ways there
here's the moth the bug that was found
in men of grace Murray hopper has
computers and here's the set of tools we
have now so we've invested a lot of time
and energy over the last 50 or 60 years
to make it harder for me as a programmer
to insert bugs into my programs right I
used to be able to pass the wrong type
to a function and see wouldn't compete
wouldn't complain about it and it would
just crash now the compiler warns me
that's as now who's we well we start out
with the first programmer ever Ada
Lovelace we get a couple of pioneers and
then we expand off and it becomes an
industry and a lot of these people did
their work on their own but we quickly
learned how to have very large teams and
kind of a factory set
working together on much larger projects
Oh an engineering solution that goes
well beyond anything we had before we
can do that with programs in a way that
we couldn't do with other things we
don't have processes set up for 200
people to collaborate on writing a novel
but we can do it you guys do it very
well in writing operating systems and
office tools and everything else so we
got into that stage and we're trying to
get to the stage where we have cs4 all
or coding for all these vary initiatives
for that so can everybody in the world
do it but we're not there yet we haven't
made a system that's accessible to
everybody yet and we want to try to get
there so I got to talk about some ways
of saying what could get us there is it
just that the programming languages have
to be a little bit better or do we need
a new way of thinking about things so
what about programming well we started
off here here's some Fortran programs
now we have these integrated
environments and they do a much better
job of actually telling you when you did
something wrong
but let's think about that process so we
have a programmer she gets an idea
organizes the thoughts mostly on
searching through Stack Overflow and
putting things together writes the
program and then you can stick the
program into a computer and now you've
invented a brand new device that serves
as a input/output machine and that
machine can go and do something in the
real world and that means that software
is fundamentally a mathematical science
so the tools we have to express things
in our programming language are
basically logical right so we have an if
statement that has a boolean
if-then-else and it's based on the
notion of proof we only ever proved the
10 line programs in our introductory
class we don't prove the large programs
but we prove properties of them and we
have unit tests and we show that those
are correct and the language we have for
doing that is based on boolean logic we
have buts are true and assert equals and
so on
we don't have more complex ways of
talking about it so what does that mean
a programmer is so here's a historic
photo this is Margaret Hamilton and this
is the code for the Apollo Lander that
she worked on and it turns out Margaret
was my boss in my very first job right
out of college so so I'm glad that she's
getting more fame now and that I own her
LEGO minifigs but what we designed a
programmer has is someone who can say in
every possible circumstance that that
Apollo computer could be in here's the
right thing to do step by step here's
what you have to do if a than this and
if B than that so that means we've made
the programmers job is like a
micromanager who's telling you
everything what to do and you do not
want to have a micromanager
so here's Darth you screw up one thing
on the space station and he's all over
you
right it's no fun working for him so
maybe our programs aren't having any
fine well you know let's not go get that
philosophical but maybe it's not so much
fun for us either do you have to go that
far so are there other ways of dealing
with the world then telling the computer
how to do it step by step
well we now have this machine learning
model of the world and the standard
model goes something like this you start
out with some labeled data I've got some
images and some labels on it and I do
some deep learning with some package and
then profit okay we're done any
questions but in reality it's more
complicated than that right so we've
we've taken the programming model where
the programmer does a job of saying step
by step what to do and we've placed it
to the model where the programmers more
like a teacher that says here's some
examples I want you to duplicate and
generalize from those examples and that
means we've made software no more longer
a mathematical science but it's more of
an empirical science or natural science
it's like doing biology I make some
observations of the world I have a
theory of the world
and then I go out and check those
theories to see if they're correct its
probabilistic rather than logical it's
uncertain and it's observational right
so it's a different way of looking at
the world different set of skills
necessary to be successful but it's
still the case that we can take the
programs that we produce we're producing
them through a learning process now
rather than writing them by hand we can
shove them into a computer and now we've
got something that can do input now put
but crucially it can observe the world
and then improve itself or or update
itself and you all know what we can do
with that we can play go we can
self-driving cars we could do machine
translation we can do all these amazing
things and we're starting to get a
toolkit to go along with this but we got
a long ways to go
right so for regular programming we've
got 50 or 60 years worth of tools here
we've only got a couple years worth of
tools and so the process is much harder
now I gave you that character of a three
step model but the realistic model is
more complex than that
so here's a realistic model and I won't
go into details although I got a whole
lecture on any one of these points and
you can ask me in the question time if
you want but the idea is that there's a
lot of work done in managing data and
then there's a lot of work in after you
build the model in deploying it
monitoring its use and updating and so
on and integrating it into a software
product and integrating the software
product into a business need I spend a
lot of time talking to startup companies
and they look at all this and they say
yeah yeah okay we've done stuff with
data before we understand that but this
is gonna be the hard part right because
look how complicated that diagram is and
I've seen the equations and they have
partial derivative signs in it and and
my math a little bit rusty and I'm
really scared about this so this is how
they estimate the time it's gonna take
for for each of these steps and then you
know we sort of help them along and they
go and do a project and afterwards they
say you know what
we were exactly wrong it's actually more
like this that the machine learning
training part that was actually pretty
easy
it was the managing the data getting the
data inputting it cleaning and so on
that was really the hard part and then
deploying it was the second hardest part
and the part in the middle was easiest
so it's big change in perception now one
of the things that's really interesting
about this part in the middle and one of
the things I think helps make it easy is
that we have this network and it's
differentiable meaning if you feed in
the input you get an output you don't
like there's something wrong with it you
can measure the difference between what
you get and what you wanted you can feed
that back you can make corrections along
the way and now the whole thing has
improved and that's great and we have
great tools and processes for doing that
but the problem is this is just one step
out of the eight and what we really want
is a workflow that we can differentiate
the whole thing right so what do I mean
by well back here these are the steps
having to do with acquiring the data
figuring out what features you want
cleaning the data and so on and if
you've got good engineers they make good
choices here you build the system you
run it it's great but a year later
everything in the world has changed and
all of a sudden the choices you made
here are no good anymore and there are
better choices to be made but nothing in
this system will tell you that it'll
just performance will start to degrade
whereas over here if something went
wrong you could automatically correct it
you have a process to do that we don't
have that here and if we want these
tools to be usable by more and users I
think we need to put the whole process
under this type of differentiable
approach so that any decision you make
here can be revisited and it'd be great
if it be automatically corrected but if
not automatically corrected at least
detect it and say we got a problem here
used to be working fine now it no longer
is somebody should go look at that ok so
we talked about what the Memex can do
exploring and organizing your thoughts
express the thoughts and follow the the
implications and we said
programming is one way to do that
machine learning is a slightly different
way to do that what else could we do
what other ways of looking at the world
would be a different way that would
maybe help us get at these goals so we
have this idea of data science and
there's this famous Venn diagram from
Drew Conway that says data science is
the intersection of these three skills
one you've got to be a little bit of a
programmer maybe not quite as
professional as as people that do it for
a living as their main job too you got
to know a little bit of statistics and
three you have to know your subject area
if you're doing biology data you got to
understand some biology if you're doing
financial you got to understand some
financial and he's broken down all these
subclasses this is considered a danger
zone if you don't know the statistics
you can get in trouble and maybe the
more programming you know the more
trouble you get in I don't like that
this is the intersection I wish it was
more like the Union that if you had some
of those skills you could be successful
and I don't like requiring somebody to
have all the skills this diagram has
also been updated by Joel gross who
added this fourth circle here this
really strikes home for B this one you
know your thesis adviser is the one who
used to know how to program but doesn't
anymore and I think Joel is also right
over here that you know in retrospect
you don't have to be that much of an
expert in statistics in that yeah you
can go wrong but most of the time you
want okay so let's take you to a non
expert so this is Makoto coca here with
his parents who are cucumber farmers in
Japan and I'm gonna let you in on a
secret he does not want to be a cucumber
farmer but somebody has to take over the
family business and they're kind of
expecting him to do so what's he gonna
do about that well he had the idea maybe
I can automate away most of that job and
the first part he looked at was sorting
the cucumbers and
he said he wasn't an expert he didn't
have that bottom of expertise in the
subject matter but he said here's these
categories I don't even know what these
letters stand for but the idea is you
got all these cucumbers and you got to
throw all the ones that look like this
into a barrel that's labeled BM and you
got to put the ones that look like this
into a label that's like labeled yes and
he said I'm I have a little bit of
mechanical engineering skill I can built
a conveyor belt put the cucumbers on
that and I can download tensorflow and I
can put a camera overhead and I think I
can sort them automatically into these
categories and it turned out he could
write now the question is who else can
do that and how much skill do you need
to be able to do something like that is
that something that takes a really
exceptional engineer or are we getting
to a point where anybody in the world
can do this kind of thing and part of
the question is what kind of
conversation do you have to have with
your system in order to build something
like this that works and these are the
kinds of things that I would expect to
be quite reasonable to have to say right
so I got to tell it that there's nine
classes of cucumber and I got to give it
some examples and I might want to give
it some hints to say there's electric
lights but also some day lights coming
in so pay attention to that and so on
and so on don't worry too much about the
prickly parts here's some examples you
got this one wrong let's talk about why
you got it wrong the background doesn't
matter
so the the conveyor belt was gray but if
it breaks and I replace it with a brown
conveyer belt don't change everything
it's the pickles that matter not the
conveyor belt and so on and so on these
are the kinds of things that be quite
reasonable to have as part of your
discussion but the way things are today
this is not the kind of conversation you
can have instead you have a conversation
like this you say well there should be
17 compositional layers and the learning
rate should be alpha equal such-and-such
in the batch size and and so on and so
on and augment the training images by
rotating them a little bit
and and optimize my hyper parameters for
me automatically right I don't have to
say all that I want those things to just
happen and I want to talk about the
subject matter and we aren't there yet
and the question is can we get there
what is it going to take and it looks
like that most of the community is not
really focused on these kinds of things
well more focused on can we come up with
a better algorithm for doing the core
part and not all these peripheral parts
about making it easier okay here's
another language for talking to our
computers it's probabilistic programming
right and I said the programming we have
now is logical rather than probabilistic
and I mean that two ways one is the the
the conditionals we have are boolean
if-then-else the variables we have have
a single value their point values I say
x equals zero I don't say X is drawn
from a probability distribution with
mean zero I I could say that but I've
said that probability distribution would
be a user to find type and wouldn't be
part of the language itself right
probabilistic programming languages give
you those types of things built-in and
they also give you the ability to work
in multiple directions right so a
regular program I go from the input to
the output only probabilistic program I
can say I observe this variable now I
wonder what that other variable is and
you aren't fixed to saying one is the
input and the other is the output so
there's many of these systems this is
Bayes DB I could have done inferred NAT
that's very another very nice system and
one way to think of this is it's like
making queries to a sequel database but
that some of the fields in the database
are not defined but are done by
inference and so here it's me it's
making query about finding satellites
with uncertain data and it can give you
this results but let's get that and say
first of all is that a good approach is
this idea of saying well maybe some
people are familiar with working with
databases can we
make a database query and the things
that are uncertain can we behind the
scenes do inference over that uncertain
part and just gloss over the fact that
there's uncertainty would that be a good
interface for dealing with computers and
here's an example question say I've got
a company I want to send out a mailing
of a special offer to some of my
customers and I say from the customer
database give me all the names and
emails from everybody whose age is when
the in this demographic and his income
it's over this amount but I don't really
have the age and the income in my
database rather I have other things that
are proxies for that and I have a models
automatically built that infers them so
some of them is going to get wrong
there'll be a few people on that are
selected that are that shouldn't have
been and a few people that are missed
it's that that should not have been but
that's probably fine the cost of not
sending the email to everybody is not
high the cost of sending a couple extra
emails is not high so this would be a
good way to program if that's my task so
I can infer those from examples but
let's say I want to say select the
diagnosis in the treatment from the
electronic medical records for this
patient ID then I don't want to treat it
like a database I don't want to say this
is a database there's a column for
diagnosis as a column for treatment
there's one definitive answer in each of
those columns tell me what that answer
is because I don't have a model that's
good enough for that and an error does
really hurt me so rather probably what I
want to do in this case is some sort of
simulation and then I want to have some
summarization that says here's the
differential diagnosis not just I'm
retrieving a single value from a
database but here's the all the spans of
possibilities and what doctors are
usually really asking is find the set of
treatments with no bad interactions such
that they're an approximate cover for
all the diagnoses so I'm not sure if you
have this in which case I would
prescribe this one antibiotic
or you might have something else and I'd
prescribe the other antibiotic since I
can't tell I'll give you them both
that's fine we've done that before now
you're covered but that's not a database
operation that's more complex and can we
come up with the right models to
distinguish between these two cases and
to make it understandable to the users
what we're doing in each of those cases
all right so that's a challenge that
would be one possible way to go is try
to extend database programming other
people have thought of it that's trying
to extend spreadsheet programming that's
another possible way to think of it but
we have the one thing that we're really
good at which is just talking and
everybody can do that I saw this thing
was was pushed at me the other day it
was an article on how to create a voice
menu that your customers will love and I
didn't have to read the article and I
know the conclusion should be don't
because nobody loves it in fact hardly
anybody can tolerate it
right so we've all seen those press 1 if
you want this press 2 if you want that
nobody wants that but we have other
examples where it works really great
unfortunately most of them are still
fictional where you can have a
conversation you can talk about anything
you want
and everything works out so we're not
quite there yet we're getting a little
bit better right in fact if I'm stuck to
a conversation where I want to say tell
me the weather play some songs show me a
recipe now we can have that conversation
and picking up the words is pretty easy
we're getting much better at that
picking up the intent for things that
are more complicated than those few
examples that's still getting hard and
the thing that I think is interesting
about this is that we have a possibility
for another phase change in the way we
do computing right so we went from
mainframes computers to personal
computers to mobile and maybe now are we
going to conversational computing well
you know if you had asked me five years
ago would people want to throw away
their keyboards and screens and just
have a speaker that sits on the on the
desk I would have said that's crazy
why would anybody want that but a lot of
people do so maybe we're going in that
direction and maybe we're displacing
this model of programming right so the
way we have it now if I want something
to happen I press one of these icons and
now I've given over control of my phone
to the company that created that app and
there's a place to get lots of these
there's some weaknesses of this model
one is because I've given over control I
have to decide what do I want to give
and when the OP is installed there's
this long list and nobody understands
them and they just press ok and if it
acts kind of flaky then they delete it
later right but we can do a much better
job presumably of privacy and security
and fairness but we aren't there yet so
one possibility is push that do a better
job of security for the apps the other
is to say maybe we shouldn't can control
over to the to the app writer maybe we
should keep control with the
conversational agent and so we have this
kind of a model where we say hi how can
I help you and I say something I want a
pizza or I want a car to appear and then
it goes off and talks to these other
services and arranges it for me and I
feel safer because I'm talking to my
agent rather than talking to some app
that I haven't got verified and it's my
agents job to protect my privacy so
maybe that will work but the systems we
have for building them and that's this
is true for for all the major vendors of
these types of products still looks much
more like those terrible phone menus
than it looks like having a real
conversation right so there are
application developer kits where I can
say what triggers do I want to respond
to and if I do what dialogue do I want
to output and then when I get a response
how do I want to respond to that so it's
very much like following these menus and
not like having a real model of how
conversation works there are
intermediate steps we could take right
so maybe instead of talking directly to
these apps I want to have intermedia
Aries right so I might have this is an
intermediary for all the ride hailing
services and this is an intermediary for
all the restaurants and if I trust them
then I could talk to them and they can
specialize that kind of sub conversation
it's not quite clear yet how this is all
going to work out right where's the
responsibility gonna be split but not
giving up control of my whole phone to
somebody else I'm keeping part of it
who does which part okay
and we've made these things really hard
to do and so here's an example on my
phone it used to be that on the maps
there was a little scale bar down at the
bottom that was displayed all the time
and I noticed that went away sometime
and I wanted to get it back so I did a
little research and I found out that I
could in fact get it back and all I had
to do was look for it on Google and then
sec ever flow and then figure out how to
root my phone and then install 200 lines
of Java and 20 lines of config file and
I would have that thing right back again
right so I could have done that but I
didn't because I thought that would have
been pretty brittle what I really wanted
to do was say hey Google put the scale
bar back on the map right but I can't do
that now it doesn't let me do it and I
find many times that part of the problem
is that so much of what we do in
programming doesn't make it into the
program so I've seen lots of cases where
we have design documents and you read
these documents and they say what a
great job you've done coming up with a
design you explored many possible user
interfaces you went out and you did
customer experiments and you tried it
a/b testing of one interface versus
another and then you made the final
recommendation which is clearly the best
out of all the choices but it's the best
if you were only allowed to choose one
possible choice but for some users in
some places it wasn't the right choice
and all these other options that got
thrown away they're not part of the
codebase they're in this paper document
only and I can't bring them back right
so
if we had a development environment that
said all these artifacts these
experiments you do are all available and
can be queried and can say hey can you
make this interface different I would
like it to look like this you can say oh
yeah you know two years ago we did a
little user experiment where we tried
that out most users didn't like it but
if you like it I can bring it back for
you
right so I think it'd be great if we
could have everything under program
control rather than having dead
non-executable documents okay here's
another example on a previous trip I was
in Boston my phone goes Bing and there's
a alert that says this is great it's got
it exactly right
return rental car to Logan Airport it's
got the right map it's got the right
place it's got the right time did
everything perfectly and then had had to
spoil it all by saying time of travel 23
minutes by bicycle and sometimes this is
not too bad because I commute to work
and it's about 23 minutes so it knows
that that's the right length of which I
usually take a bicycle but it did not
understand what return rental car meant
and I thought about should I file a bug
report and then I said nobody did their
job wrong right and so if you look at
who did what and here's that kind of a
simplified version somebody's a job was
to parse the email from Hertz and
extract an event an event has a location
at a time and so on and then somebody
else's job was to plan a trip and from
my location to the destination at that
time they planned a pretty good trip and
then somebody else's job was to create
the alert and put that up that was all
right as long as you're considering the
title of the event as just being a
string everybody's job was perfect but
if the title of the event actually meant
something then it's probably not a good
idea to take a bicycle and so the
problem is that as we're dealing with
these uncertain worlds and dealing with
the real world on the outside interface
has just become more complicated and
we're used to this idea of
saying interfaces should be simple right
so let's go back to the early days of
the web we had this amazing thing you
could have a form and I can fill in my
name and my email in my zip code and
that could get passed back and forth
between me and the web page and and a
server but the most complicated thing I
had to do to verify this type of
information was say well the emails
probably have an @ sign in it and the
zip code should be five digits and I
could do that either on the server side
or on the web size that's fine and we
tried to keep these interfaces as simple
as possible and it's famous quote from
Alan Perlis that says if you have a
procedure with ten parameters you
probably missed some and so this design
idea is keep the interfaces as small as
possible because if they get complex
nobody can deal with it and that makes a
lot of sense when you're dealing with
this very concrete data of just a few
entries like your zip code but if we're
trying to talk to one of these devices
then there are no bounds on what that
interface should be right so I need the
whole grammar of English both English in
general and my specific dialect and the
speech patterns those are the same and
the background information of everything
that's happened recently and all the
world knowledge of what a rental car is
and what it means to return it and so on
all those have to be shared between me
as a dialogue participant and my my
speech assistant there and the question
is how are we going to pass them back
and forth right am I gonna pass
everything I know well one would take
too long and the the bandwidth charges
would be too high and secondly I don't
want to share everything I know because
there's privacy and implications so how
are we going to figure out where this
gets shared and who pushes what who
queries when you query what are you
allowed to see we don't know how to
express this information and we don't
know how to share it and break up those
tasks and so the problem is we're trying
to take this very cloud like or fluffy
real-world messy situation and put it in
to a square hole and sometimes it's a
good fit but most of the time it's not
okay now I wanna so most of the things
I've talked about have been kind of on
the programming side I want to talk
about another way of talking about the
world in design thinking and I spent
some time with architects and what they
do is they have their own language for
exploring through possible designs and
here they're trying to build a building
that's going to be on on this
intersection here and they're going to
meet certain requirements for what the
building has to do and they go through
all these possible sketches and they
have kind of design patterns for how
buildings should be built and they
explore those possibilities here's
another example where they said let's
start out with this design then say well
we wanted to be more varied and we want
to fill in the various functions that
happened in different places and now
it's important to have a pass through
here so instead of having to pass
through once we'll squish it together so
only half pass through once and then the
way the sunlight goes that will affect
the height and they have this whole
process for generating these these
possibilities and it's not in a
programming language and it's not in a
conversational language you know if
anything it's kind of more like playing
with Lego blocks so is that the kind of
tools we should provide them give them a
bunch of Lego box and then have overhead
camera that's tracking what they're
doing is that would that be a good way
for them to express the knowledge they
know they also go and draw diagrams but
that takes a lot of work so can we
automate that process of drawing those
diagrams and then can we get to the
points of implication right so I talked
about understanding what you're talking
about publishing what you're talking
about
but then there's also drawing the
implications and can we build a system
where we say here the constraints here's
the kinds of things I know about this
building now go ahead and automatically
generate a dozen possibilities given
those constraints and now I can say oh
yeah I think number four and number
seven look pretty good and number ten
and eleven will never work now generate
another dozen given that feedback
and have that kind of iterative process
right so I think that's the kind of way
that a architect would like to interact
with the system and can we come up with
a language to do that okay so it's
trying to go through the words of the
title as we make program and there's one
word left over and that's the word May
which talks about possibilities
preferences utilities desires needs
wants right so these are the things we
have to be able to express to our
programs if our programs are built on
machine learning and they're built on
optimizing something then we have to
tell our programs what we want what we
really really want and we have a
tradition and a set of fables that talk
about problems in doing this so here's
poor King Midas he was asked for a
software specification of what he wanted
and he came up with I want everything I
touched to turn to gold and then he's
looking sad because he realized there
was a bug in his specification and his
food is turned to gold and that's not
going to work for him right so that's a
cautionary tale if he should have done a
better job of coming up with a
specification we also have the fable of
the genie in the lamp here the genies
caught on and says you're not allowed to
wish for more wishes right so that's one
trick but this recipient is clever and
she starts off with some gambits that
it's not clear where it's going I wish
that my wishes be calculated an absolute
value and the genius of watt then she
says now I wish for a thousand fewer
wishes
and that's why nobody likes my petitions
all right so there's unexpected
consequences of basically of using
language right there's one more and so I
did on on the occasion of April first I
did this piece you can find on media
then this is about the classic science
fiction movie Forbidden Planet if you
remember that movie the space explorers
go to an alien planet everybody on the
planet is dead they have to figure out
what happened and eventually they
stumble across a data center and in that
data center they discover that the
civilization had launched overnight a
new software product which was you think
whatever you want
and then it will automatically appear
right so it's kind of like this
Star Trek Earl Grey tea hot they gave
everybody at once the capability to do
that and what they didn't recognize was
at night they all had nightmares and
monsters came and killed them all right
so that was a site reliability
engineering fail and you can read about
it in this last Suites of the crawl so
one of the bug fixes for King Midas or
the genie or this crawl civilization
well one you know if King Midas had just
said everything will turn to gold but I
want an undo function he would have been
fine or if he'd done some simulations
first or if you've done some small-scale
tests before launching the whole thing
okay don't give everybody in the world
overnight the capability to do
everything let's do a couple user tests
first and then once you've done the
regular test let's do some adverse arrow
tests let's bring in some red team's to
try to break the system let's monitor
and deploy it let's have the ability to
shutdown right so there must been one
monster that came out first
and once you got a customer reports
should hit the shutdown or at least the
roll back to the previous version they
didn't have any of that they didn't have
anybody on call I guess let's specify a
prompt for unsafe actions do you really
want to conjure monsters from the edge
yes or no and they have a process of
continued evolution and improvement and
then I think a big part of it is don't
over rely on language right so all these
things
the idea is you can't trust a single
sentence of language you say what you
want
and the genie interprets it the wrong
way and you don't get what you really
want but and and we have ways of dealing
with that right so we write laws and
regulations but we know that just those
sentences aren't quite enough so we also
have case law where we say here's an
example of what we meant when we wrote
that law and I think often we can do
better by relying on cases rather than
relying on on just language okay so
we're close to wrapping up so I said I
don't like traditional programming where
you're a micromanager and you're telling
the computer what to do step by steps so
what are the possibilities well the
Memex user is a researcher the machine
learning person is a teacher we may
think it's more like a leader or a
philosopher or a poet so here's a great
example of a leader General Patton said
don't tell people how to do things tell
them what to do and let them surprise
you with the result all right so what he
meant is say go capture that hill
don't say we'll take two platoons up
this side and three platoons up the
other side because the people on the
ground are going to know better than the
general is what's the right thing to do
so let them do the right thing and
surprise you and and so that's a perfect
model for machine learning approach
don't constrain the system you have to
do it one way just say this is my
objective and if we're gonna have that
objective then we got to be clear about
what is it that we really really want so
let's go to two other philosopher poets
and of course Mick is most famous for
his statement on on what we want can't
always get what you want you get what
you need but I think Mick got it exactly
backwards and I I would rather go with
Bobby here or Nobel laureate there's a
less famous statement with the opposite
conclusion because these are the things
that we need but we built an exquisite
large system for measuring what we want
with every click and these are the
things we said we want and therefore
that's what we get and it's not bad
enough that I go and spend a couple
hours playing Angry Bird and say oh man
that was stupid I wish I had those hours
back it's it's too late for me unless I
invent a time machine
but what's worse is now it's too late
for all of you as well because every one
of my clicks was a vote and it gets
recommended to you and then you do it
and it's a vote to somebody else and
it's a virus that spreads and spreads
and it's more of these short term this
is what I want and none of it feeds back
into what I need because that's the way
the marketplace works and so no matter
what we can do in building better
languages and and building more secure
and fair systems we've got to have a
marketplace that's aligned with giving
us what we want now there is some good
news right so not doomed to have this
always fail there's this famous work on
the tragedy of the Commons and some
people have a pessimistic conclusion
that that means if there's a shared
resource Roe is gonna screw it up but
Elinor Ostrom got the Nobel Prize for
saying you know what in reality it
doesn't really work that way that
society's going back hundreds of years
have figured out how to use these shared
resources and there's a list of design
patterns there and you can look those up
how we can go and set up our systems to
make them more reliable to do a better
job of sharing what we have among
everybody and helping out the community
as a whole within the market
so why don't I stop there and we can
open it up for questions do you also see
these things coming together additional
programming
yeah so so certainly they can complement
each other I think they have a lot to
say to each other and you're starting to
see a lot of things now where machine
learning is being used to optimize
traditional programs so we've been
working with David Patterson who says
you know when I'm building an operating
system I have all these parameters
what should the block size be and he
does this similar kind of design
document where he finds the optimal
value but that might change over time so
now we're thinking maybe that should all
be done with machine learning to say in
this particular case in this
implementation what's the right value
for these parameters let's compute that
rather than make the programmer specify
it so I think there's a lot of room for
interaction of that kind I've never seen
a sponge before we work on something
like taking the space taking the scale
bar and putting it back on the map in
terms of the specified specification of
what the user wants don't we need to
work on the composability of the widgets
yeah how do I know that when I put the
scale walk back and clobber the rest of
that right why right and so I think
that's exactly why we don't have these
infinite number of possibilities right
because it's one thing to say scale bar
on or off there's two possibilities
there sure let's give them both but if
there's 20 different objects we don't we
don't have time to test two to the
twentieth of them so we need more like
constraint language to say if I were to
add this one more thing how would
everything else change and that has to
be specified well enough so that you
don't have to test them all ahead of
time but it works and
and I guess part of it is you know if it
screwed up then give the user a way to
recover so I know that we found this at
Google and I think a lot of other people
have you see progression of having fewer
and fewer types of customization and I
think a lot of that is because users
make bad choices and then they blame us
right so we used to have this thing that
says how many results do you want per
page and everybody said 100 that's the
biggest number and so they set their
personal settings 200 results per page
and then they started saying oh man
Google so much slower than it used to be
I'm not gonna use it anymore because
it's too slow right and so we either
have to have some kind of warning or
have to say you know what if you're
worried about slowness I can fix that I
can set it back to ten results per page
and it's going to get faster again so we
need some these different settings need
some way to interact with each other and
communicate about what they're doing Wow
under invested areas of AI so a lot of
things you know I mentioned like the
fairness and so on that seems really
important kind of having a better
understanding of where your data comes
from and what you can do with it I'm
really continue to hope that robotics is
going to break through that you know it
kind of feels like we are now with
robotics where we were with personal
computers and somewhere in the 1970s
where you could buy a kit and it was
really interesting to play with but
didn't really do anything useful but
then by a decade later everybody had one
in their home and so I think we're at
similar place now where you can buy a
vacuum cleaner robot but it can't do
much else and hopefully we're going to
get better at that and then
tracking with great interest how these
conversational systems work do we really
want to communicate by voice rather than
communicate by screen and keyboard and
if so how will the programming of that
play out I think that's really
interesting programming but with more
general terms computing is assuming more
and more complexity and taking on more
and more tasks and this comment of a
user control and setting so in the long
run will you see what you see the role
of computing in people's lives like how
far how expansive should this become and
what what should it do for the human
surviving general yeah so it's so what
should the role of programming be and I
guess there's there's two parts to that
what what would what should the role of
somebody else's programming be on me so
what tools that were built by somebody
can I use and we certainly seen a lot of
those I think where I'm excited about
the possibilities coming up in areas
like health I think we could do a better
job in these research type areas of
helping people understand things you
know when you start looking at how many
people are advocates of the Flat Earth
theory you know you sort of think can't
we do a little bit better job of helping
people understand the world better so
that's one aspect of programming is is
how can one programmer help someone else
and then the other aspect is how much
should everybody be a programmer and
what can they do for themselves how much
can I say I want to build something
that's just for me I can't expect
somebody else to provide it for me
but it's for my own use and both in
terms of having a finished product that
I want and also just the process of
dealing with it will help me think about
things help me model the world help me
understand it better and I think a lot
of people are missing out on that that
most of us in this room have that
capability to do that we find something
interesting we can explore it we can get
an answer but most people don't have
that capability
and if we could give that to them maybe
not in a traditional programming
language but something that's accessible
to them would help them open up their
world thank you for providing so many
perspectives about different ways of
programming I was especially delighted
when you mentioned design thinking and I
wanted to know in your opinion what do
you think is makes ml and AI a special
interest of a design material hmm and
how that impacts the way the sign of now
think what is so different about it from
everything else that they had to
interact with before yeah so a question
was what makes machine learning and AI
different as a material for thinking one
of the conversations I had this this
morning was with some someone who was
saying you know I felt this game-playing
program and it started playing better
than me and that that was a
life-changing moment that I could see
that something that I created could
surpass me and I think that happens more
often in machine learning and AI than it
does in other places you know so
certainly you know I could have
programmed something that would multiply
ten digit numbers a lot better than I
could but that's not a life-changing
moment for me it's it's these other
things where you say wow this is really
understanding something at a deep level
how did it do that can I understand how
that happened I think that's what's
different about AI what would he see the
biggest impact for quantum AI in the
future for quantum AI yeah that's a
great question you know up to a couple
years ago I was hoping that I was old
enough that I would get to die before I
had to worry about
and so I wouldn't have to understand
anything about it now I'm not so sure
and not just because my health is
looking good but looks like Quantum's
get might be getting somewhere
the the Quan guys at Google have for the
last two years have promised me this is
a year for quantum supremacy and they
haven't delivered yet but maybe they're
getting close yeah I think a lot of the
things that I want to do would not be
helped that much right so a lot of
things I want to do is here's a trillion
web pages I want to do a small amount of
computation on each one and then I want
to sum that up so for that kind of thing
it's IO and pushing things through and
having a quantum computer is not going
to contribute to that if I have a neural
net with a million parameters it's
probably not going to help on that
either but if I can get a smaller number
of parameters and if the algorithms get
better I can see a potential future
where we can optimize those parameters
much better using a quantum computer
then then what we can do now and we're
not there yet but I think that's a
possibility sometime maybe in my
lifetime particularly answering a
question there about you know putting it
in the voice or in some critical
components of the software
infrastructure it becomes even more
important so I want to have your
reflections on the current state and
because that's something at least we all
systems people worry about yeah okay so
question was about debug ability and
there's a lot of words that go into that
there's big emphasis now on explainable
AI people talk about transparency and
Trust so these are all related in some
way and you know so I said it's with
traditional programs
we like the story that we could prove
them correct for complex ones we never
quite get there but we can do more and
more and there's more things that we can
prove we can sue even if we can't prove
the whole program correct we can often
prove properties of programs with
machine learning we've taken a step
backwards with respect to that it's
harder to prove something and some of
that is because of the machine learning
algorithm itself makes it harder to come
up with a proof and some of it is
because the domains we're dealing with
are not amenable to proof right so if I
so let me make one point I'll get back
to that right so if I you have a program
that I say this program is capable of
sorting a list of numbers I could see
how I could prove that program correct
but if I have a program that says you're
gonna give me a web query and I'm going
to sort the webpages by rank order there
is no correct answer for that and that
has nothing to do with whether I used a
neural net to do it it just has to do
that the problem has no proof so we have
to be able to deal with that now people
in control theory have all I've already
been dealing with this type of problem
where they say we're gonna build a
controller and what they really like to
do is say we're only going to allow a
linear controller because then we have
lots of knife's proofs of course they're
only proving the model is correct they
aren't proving that the thing in the
physical world is correct but if if the
model corresponds to the physical world
then they have some nice proofs as soon
as their models get nonlinear then they
give up on the proofs but they start
talking about kind of envelopes of I
think the system will stay within these
types of boundaries and so I think
that's the kind of approach we should
take for machine learning we should say
I can't guarantee everything about the
results but it's going to stay here you
know with one minus Epsilon probability
it's going to be within this type of
envelope and I think we need more of
that
and then we just need better
testing in general right so I think
we're already in software at a point
where most of what we rely on is testing
rather than proof and we just may need
some better test regimes now there is a
big issue right so you mentioned this
this issue of online data and continual
updating right nice to be talking with
Eric earlier that it used to be you guys
once a year stamped the golden CD and
put it into a cardboard box and and
called up some trucks to take them over
to stores that was so quaint when we
used to do that right and so you could
invest an awful lot into testing that if
you only had to test once a year before
you shipped it then we got to the point
where we have Web Services where they're
being updated every day and you can't do
the same type of testing every day so
you have to have tiered testing we're
gonna do a lot of tests first and then
we're gonna have the monthly tests and
the weekly tests and the daily tests and
now with online learning we have the
second by second test of every new data
point that comes in we do a little
gradient descent and we change our
parameters a little bit we can't run all
the tests every millisecond so we have
to have even more of this tiered
approach and and maybe we need more
types of alerts of saying well things
are different now today than they were
yesterday and then some filters of that
of saying well it's fine because today's
Christmas so we expect it to be
different than yesterday and so on and
so on people come up and just meet Peter
directly and have a chat so sure so you
spoke about the potential for
conversational systems and I'm curious
because if I'm typing in Jupiter
notebooks where you've ever been
clicking icons on
GUI in some sense I'm having a
conversation with the computer so I
guess my question is how far along the
spectrum do we have to get before we
start to see the benefits of see us for
all do we have to get all the way up to
like the colonial natural conversation
where there's something yeah I think we
should use the right thing at the right
time right so so everybody has their
natural language whether it's English or
Spanish or whatever it is but for lots
of the things we want to do we also have
specialized language and we have
programming languages you know if I want
to play music I don't use English words
I use music notation and I think we will
see more of that of saying here's a task
you want to do here's a specialized way
of doing that interaction some of it
will be natural language some of it will
be the notation you used to maybe you'll
have to learn a few programming type
concepts and I think the future will be
specialized solutions like that for
particular tasks and then the
generalized part will be more just the
training this idea right so you know I
don't really like this phrase of
programming or coding for everybody I
would rather have it be something like
model building or problem solving for
everybody and that programming is one
way to express models and solve problems
but there are other ways as well just
this idea that you can create a model
you can debug it you can see the results
and the implications that's what's
important and you know whether it's in
JavaScript or Python or something else I
think is less important
[Applause]